dennis kommentar sehr aussagekräftig
[ __ ] ja gut ich mein ich habe erst
seit zwei jahren freundin aber kann man
ja natürlich bei unters video schreiben
warum auch nicht
er wollte etwas gelaufen ist willkommen
bei einem neuen video ich habe immer
gedacht
man kriegt ja ab und zu daten schon mal
wieder etwas was heißt ab und zu täglich
eigentlich diese etwas und schöneren
kommentare beziehungsweise hater
kommentare ich habe einfach mal ein paar
rausgesucht ich habe da nicht jetzt
unbedingt die genommen wo einfach nur
drin steht du bist scheiße du kleiner
tönung und so weiter sondern schon die
etwas eher aussagekräftigeren und die
auch viel spaß mit dem video falls euch
gefällt mir erst noch mal sehen was auf
jeden fall noch unterschreibt in die
kommentare und wirklich auch viel spaß
so tut mir leid ich muss heute vom
laptop aus vorlesen aber ich fange man
mit dem ersten kommentare der du hast
eine freundin mit so einem niveau niveau
mit warum nicht also du wirst mir sagen
mein niveau ist nicht gut und du
schreibst dani womit ich meine ja man
sollte so was vielleicht nicht schreiben
wenn seine eigene rechtschreibung
katastrophales niveau hat deswegen tut
mir leid aber ich kann einen kommentar
nicht verstehen so passt auf weil der
nicht so kommt es auch lustig und zwar
wurde der unter 1
logos bei mädchen wie du von mir
geschrieben du machst for you von stevie
kannst nicht selber erfinden
außerdem ist überhaupt nicht lustig ja
was nur auf erstens es gibt von diesem
glauben videos auf youtube wirklich
530.000 milliarden also das gibt's
wirklich da gibt es alles zwei drei vier
fünf sechs mal jedes neue und auf
youtube ist auch so es ist einfach alles
ein clown bzw
ein neuer also es gibt alles auf youtube
irgendwie was es nicht gibt und wenn man
irgendwas macht dann hat man das
irgendwo geklaut ist einfach so was
heißt ihr cloud man hat das unbewusste
klar sagen wir mal so und ihr könnt
nicht sagen was ist von dem oder den
geklaut weil wie gesagt bei novus ist es
klar man klaut immer immer partner von
irgendwem man gar nicht kennt glaubt ja
schade ja der nächste kommentar hat auch
irgendwie da hat der leser das video
nicht ganz verstanden und zwar war das
okay ich gebe zu das video gefällt mir
selber nicht mehr so gut es war so
beeindruckt man jedes mädchen
beziehungsweise es war halt ein
ironisches video es war alles ironie und
war das vielleicht ein bisschen zu ernst
genommen sie schreibt so beeindruckt du
kein mädchen deine freundin
mir schon leid ist ja schön dass du so
mit viel biss aber ich würde dennoch
vielleicht mal die beschreibung lesen
dann kommt man auch nicht auf so was nur
weil beschreibung lesen hilft immer und
ich war es die fürs nächste mal danke
der nächste kommentar ist sehr
aussagekräftig [ __ ] ja gut ich
mein ich habe erst seit zwei jahre
freundin aber kann man ja natürlich bei
unters video schreiben warum auch nicht
und dann haben wir hier direkt als
nächstes das auch gut mann bist du ein
opfer nehmen wir ein beispiel anleihen
tv und co zumindest was die videos
angeht ja gut ob ich jetzt seiner
meinung nach ein opfer bin oder nicht
ist deine seine freie meinung und so
aber das zweite kann ich nicht ganz
verstehen warum ich jetzt so mir ein
beispiel anleihen nehmen soll weil ich
meine
wieso soll ich irgendwie nach machen
sollte jetzt zehnmal so meinen grimassen
zeigen im video wie erz macht oder wie
hältst du das rennen also das kann ich
jetzt nicht ganz nachvollziehen weil die
zuschauer wollen ja immer dass man nicht
andere leute nach machen da und ich
verstehe deinen kommentar gibt gar
keinen sinn
du kannst nach deiner meinung ist so
jeder jeden nachmachen dann und dann per
youtube scheiße
er ist auch sehr aussagekräftig du wirst
du die scheiße was immer dann ein ganz
liebes ist wenn ihr auch noch dahinter
schreiben würde und warum dazu ist nur
weil wenn dann nur sowas kann ich nicht
ganz so viel mit anfangen anfangen
anfangen und das ist auch gut versteckt
stress ohne grund genau was hat er denn
freunde für ein problem alter die nutzt
sich richtig aus wann die schlägt ich
die ganze zeit ohne grund von mir gibt
es auf jeden fall einen blick dislike ja
gut ist aber natürlich eine weile
allerdings erst bei dir auch besser du
würdest einfach mal ein bisschen
nachdenken und es gibt keine freunde die
einfach ihren freund 10.000 mal einfach
so ohne grund schickt das war ja sinn
des videos davon gibt's schon vier
videos hintereinander ist die
beschreibung das ist alles ich ernst
gemeint ist und dann ist auch alles gut
und dankeschön hoffentlich liest du das
ja leute ich hab jetzt weiß einfach
kommentare beantwortet es ist eigentlich
immer ganz lustig auf so etwas
einzugehen beziehungsweise es zu lesen
mich stört es jetzt noch nicht ganz so
da gibt es wahrscheinlich schlimmere
fälle da geht das dann schon so an die
person an
bei mir selbst nicht ganz so krass ist
legen könnt ihr gerne weitere kommentare
schreiben kein problem
und ja ich will sagen wie gesagt bock
auf teil zwei dann lassen doch nach oben
da hier ist instagram eingeblendet
könnte auf jeden fall mal abchecken hier
auf der linken seite ist weiter mit
meinem metzgers war dinge die du die die
mädchen an jungs stehen mit meinem
kumpel und hier auf der anderen seite
habe ich mal wieder fragen beantworten
berger checken wir sehen uns dann
samstag wieder rein